So are we closer to curing CLL? I think so. These are my disclosures.
So we'll start with a brief history lesson. I had to fish this slide out, no pun intended.
This is a cohort of patients enrolled in the 90s with CLL who are being observed for their
survival outcomes. And you can see here, patients with favorable risk cytogenetics or molecular
profile have the best outcomes. But for those high-risk patients like deletion 17P, overall
survival is less than three years. So what were our tools back then, and how far have we come?
So bear with me with this slide. This is my first attempt at using AI to create one. I think it did
an okay job. Back in the 90s and early 2000s, our tools were traditional chemotherapy,
fludarabine, chlorambucil, rituximab, bendamestine, ofatumab were the big wins back then.
In the 2010s, that's when we moved into the targeted era, right? We have our BTK inhibitor
ibrutinib, PI3A1, and we have our B2K inhibitor ibrutinib. So we have our B2K inhibitor ibrutinib,
B2K inhibitor ibrutinib, PI3A1, and B2K inhibitor ibrutinib. So we have our B2K inhibitor ibrutinib,
B2K inhibitor ibrutinib, B2K inhibitor ibrutinib, B2K inhibitor ibrutinib, and of course our BCL2
inhibitor venetoclax. And we have had success with this. So this is long-term follow-up from
Resonate 2, looking at ibrutinib in treatment-naive patients with CLL. The median progression-free
survival with ibrutinib was almost nine years, and this held up even for those high-risk patients
with mutated TP53, unmutated IGHV, deletion 11q. And at nine years, our median overall survival
had still not been reduced. So we have our B2K inhibitor ibrutinib, B2K inhibitor ibrutinib,
and this is true even in those high-risk patients. We see similar success with the
second-generation B2K inhibitors. Acalabrutinib's data in Elevate TN at six years, median PFS still
has not been reached. From Sequoia, we have data with Xanabrutinib in deletion 17q patients,
regardless of your IGHV mutation status. At five years, more than 70% of patients are progression
free. With venetoclax, we have learned now that
fixed-duration therapy is feasible, right? This is data with venobin from CLL14. These are time-to-next
treatment curves. So for our favorable-risk patients, they can go several years without
needing another line of therapy. Even our higher-risk patients can benefit, albeit for
shorter durations. And now we're in the next frontier with oral doublets. With Captivate,
patients got fixed duration of ibrutinib and venetoclax. In five and a half years,
we still haven't reached our median PFS. For high-risk patients,
a little bit lower, but that's a great concept. And of course, we have Amplify with the calibrutinib
and venetoclax. This combination has also recently been FDA-approved for treatment-naive patients
without delt 17p. We now have more promising sequencing data. From the core registry,
we know that venetoclax is a very effective option after covalent PTK inhibitors. We have data from
Captivate showing retreatment with IV after IV is an effective option. At the Summer Congress,
last year, we saw preliminary data from RevengeG showing venobin as a very reasonable
or looks promising after venobin. And of course, we have data from HOVON 159 showing that you can
use AV after ven plus CD20. Despite these incredible advances, there's still an unmet
need that remains. For patients who are refractory to covalent PTK inhibitor and venetoclax, their
progression-free survival to the next line of therapy has traditionally been quite poor. So
this is an area where we're going to have to look at how we're going to be able to
focus on this area that we really need to focus. And luckily, we have made success there.
So over the next few days, you're going to hear more about the second-generation covalent PTK
inhibitors, acalabrutinib and venetoclax. You're going to hear about the covalent PTK
ipertabrutinib. I'll be talking about that tomorrow. You'll be hearing more about CAR-T
cell therapy, which now has an FDA approval for CLL, and a totally new class of drugs known as
BTK degraders.